[Music]
good morning welcome to this incredibly
early Thursday morning slot we traded a
lot of favors to get this slot so it's
really nice to see so many of you out
here for those of you as well on the
livestream and watching the recording
thank you for giving us your time as
well my name is Dominic I'm an
engineering manager on the Google Play
console
my name is also Dominic I'm product
manager for the Android app bundle my
fun fact is this is the fifth Google i/o
I've worked on but the first time I
presented a session so I'm very excited
to be here and my name is Vitor I'm a
product manager at Google Play working
on increasing your app install success
in update rate hi everyone my name is
Pierre and I'm an engineering manager on
the Android app bundle and dynamic
delivery great so the focus of this
session is going to be to introduce you
to some of the tools that you can use to
optimize your app size and boost
acquisitions we're gonna split the
session into three parts first I'm going
to talk a little bit about the factors
that impact your apps install success
rate on Google Play then I'm gonna hand
over to my colleague Vitor who's going
to talk about some of the work that we
do in the background and Google Play to
help your install success rate and then
finally we'll hand over to DOM and
Pierre who are going to walk through
what you can do on your side to help
your install success rate and the
tooling that we have that can support
you in that so to set some context in
2018 we delivered a hundred billion
installations to our users that's about
eight billion a month now that works out
when we look at the amount of data as 22
exabytes of data that's a lot
it's 22 trillion gigabytes and I know
we're playing big number bingo here so I
want to try and bring that back to
something more concrete so in 2005 the
global traffic on the Internet
was 22 exabytes and that's the year that
YouTube launched so we like to think of
this that the Google Play app
distribution network last year was the
size of the Internet back in 2005
so this is why we care about the amount
of data that we end up delivering to
users
now what drives your installs success
rate there are millions of users that
come through the Play Store looking for
apps to install and they might be
searching for your app they might see
ads or they might get a recommendation
either way at some point they end up on
your app listing page they're going to
read the reviews they're going to look
at the screenshots the videos your store
listing and hopefully they'll make the
decision to click that install button
but that is not the end of the story
that is not an acquisition until that
app has been downloaded and installed
onto the device there's a lot that can
happen between those two steps let's
take a look at some of them when we
looked at our data we found that 30% of
the time that installation doesn't fully
complete so that means that one that a
third of the time that a user decides to
install your app they don't end up with
it on your device so what happens and
what can we do to improve this turns out
when we look into it that there are
three main reasons for this drop-off
there's the internal free space on the
device there's the time it takes to
download the app and there's the cost of
the data involved I'm going to go into
each of these in more detail so first
space this is not just a problem for
emerging markets the internal free
storage on devices this is a problem
that we see across North America Europe
everywhere that we look and what we've
seen in our data is that out of our over
2 billion users a third of them 28
percent have less than one gig of free
internal free space now how does that
affect your users well
when the user tries to install an app
but the Play Store will determine if
there's enough free space for that
installation on the device and if we
determine that there's not we won't
download that app we won't waste the
users data what we will do though is pop
up an uninstall wizard that encourages
the user to free up some space now it's
possible that the user won't be able to
or won't want to remove some of the apps
that they have to make room for your app
and Vito is going to talk a little bit
later on about some of the improvements
that we've made to the uninstall wizard
and some of the ramifications that that
can have the second issue is time now
it's fairly obvious I think that the
larger your app download size the longer
it takes to download that out what may
be slightly less obvious is how
impatient some of your users might be
with the time it takes and what we see
is the larger the app download size the
more potential there is for the user to
cancel that download and similarly the
longer it takes to download your app the
more chance there is that the user is
either gonna have a network error or is
going to move out of their coverage and
either case will end up erroring out and
not getting the download the third thing
we talked about is cost so we take for
granted Wi-Fi or practically unlimited
data plans but that is not the case for
the majority of our users around the
world and the cost of their data can be
significant so when they try to download
your app when they see how much data
it's going to take to download it many
of them will immediately cancel that
download so we have space we have time
and we have cost but we wanted to go a
little bit further than just finding out
why things were not completing and we
wanted to come up with something a
little bit more quantifiable to share
with you today
so we developed a model that maps the
size reduction or increase of your app
download with the eventual install
success rate and what we found out from
our model is that for every three Meg's
that you can save on your download size
you'll get a 1% increase in install
success rate or to put it another way
every feature that you add to your app
that increases the size of the download
will have to be traded off with the
eventual acquisition loss so there's a
few of the ways in which size can affect
your install success rate what I'd like
to do now is to hand over to Vitor who
can talk through some of the things that
we've been doing in the background and
how that can help
Thank You Dominic so great so let's
start talking now about how Google Play
can help you to make even better
performance and things that we can do
automatically for you
it may be wondering first why were we
talking about these things they're
automatic if it's automatic well we're
talking about this so that you as a
developer can have an end-to-end view of
the entire funnel and knowing that
optimize your app to work better within
his architecture and we will point out a
few different things that we do that you
can actually work with and perform even
better so we will talk about five
features today we will start talking
about one for space show for time and
then shoe for cost great so let's jump
straight ahead and talk about space as
Dominic was saying space is a huge
barrier so out up there we have three
out of ten users that don't have a ton
of space they only have one gigabyte
left so even if cost is not an issue
even if time is not an issue we know
that these users might simply not be
able to install your app and that's a
shame so what we do here is we have a
feature called the uninstall wizard that
you can see here on the screen that says
users help them to free up space show
how much space they need to free up and
gives a few options we have actually
improved this feature quite a bit in
2019 as measured by what we call the
recovery rate which is how many users
are able to use this dialog and actually
proceed to the installation what did we
do one we change the UI so that it's
much easier to use
so we've highlighted the relevant
information we highlight how much space
needs to be clear it's easier to select
and easy to find these apps and we have
seen a big change in performance as a
result next we also change the ranking
so that we highlight apps they're large
apps are not used and users can easily
find them so success rating proves why
this matters one as this feature becomes
better it helps you guys like it's
something that actually becomes even
more successful and you get more
installs Chiu has to me prove this
feature to a large apps are more likely
to be uninstalled so that's actually
something that you should think about
because if your app is larger used to
suffer more with uninstalls and as Tom
and Pierre will talk later there are a
lot of
that we provide for you that help you to
monitor this and understand how we can
actually make our app smaller so now
let's talk about time so time is an
issue because people are impatient
people have a lot of things going on
people don't want to be like waiting at
a screen for something to load they want
to just be playing the game or using a
new app and people can so that's just
what happens what we can do here is we
can make the artifacts make the apk is
smaller and we do that using compression
for new installs we automatically on
average make 10% reductions on the size
that was submitted to us and that's
something that's great it just helps you
without anything different and for
updates the improvement is even more
dramatic we use patching comparing the
version that is available on the device
versus the version that's got to be
downloaded and when we do that we
actually reduce the total apk size
download by 85% so updates are much
smaller and much more likely to be
successful and one thing that here that
you can do as a developer to help us is
related to uncompressed native libraries
because of compression if there are
libraries uncompressed our compression
works better so we can make things
smaller and especially we can make the
update the updates more so talking about
native libraries this is something new
that we are announcing here today and
we're really excited it's a feature that
is being used for Google Play instant
which is instant games so you may go to
the app listing page and you see a
button saying try now that button allows
you to click and easily play a game
really fast or use an app without
something different and in that
situation try now it's now you we need
to make this really fast and this is
really important so that it's really
small how we can do this we were looking
at a few options in what we notice is
apps I actually have a lot of share
content so on the slide here you can see
a few different boxes you have grey
boxes which are actually content that is
specific to each app so in the example
game a and game B they might be assets
they may be sounds there are things that
make the game unique
then you have this blue boxes which are
a game engine a game engine is actually
something that a lot of people use and
there are a few of them and some are
very popular and are there pretty much a
lot of games and why should we be
downloading this thing over and over
again if we may already have something
on a device now we went to recently like
we didn't do this actually we everything
was like a black box we really will just
know that this is the same every
download game a game be without knowing
the difference between this content
inside each apk what we could do there
is something much different and much
more interesting is we could tell that
this user is a gamer this user has Wi-Fi
so data is not such a big issue for
these folks and then what we can do is
we prefetch a library and we keep it on
the cache and then when we go and click
on try now what happens is we download
only the specific game assets and we'll
reassemble the apk on the device so that
the download size is much smaller and
the user can jump into the experience
much faster in this pilot with instant
games we are seeing savings of up to 40%
in download size which is massive and
should make a huge difference in
conversion and engagement with these
games
so jumping now in to cost so cost is
something that is really easy for us to
forget cost is because well like if
you're watching it in the live streaming
or if you're here in i/o with Wi-Fi we
don't think about these things you are
streaming and lot of megabytes and not
really thinking about how much are we
consuming in data but a lot of users
don't think like that and they have
limited data plans and they need to be
very careful with every megabyte these
leads to different behaviors in these
markets one thing that people do it is
very popular are peer-to-peer
applications and you can find them in
the Play Store there a bunch of them and
how it works is you have for example
your phone and a phone from a friend and
you create automatically a Wi-Fi
connection a local Wi-Fi connection any
transfer files so that there's no cost
and this works offline and this is
something that users love well people
don't do this only with files like music
videos and things like that they also do
it with apps
and there are a lot of problems with
apps security we don't know like they
might not the provenance of this my know
is not compatible and that's actually
quite dangerous we actually solve this
problem by creating a new API that was
launched in the end of last year to fix
exactly this and that DGP apps can
integrate what it does is they check the
apk to make sure that is actually a play
apk chew it actually makes sure that his
apk is compatible with this other device
so that the transfer just works entry we
also make sure to be app the user
library so updates metrics for
developers like you guys you find
everything in the console later and
that's great so that's something that is
new and it's pretty exciting then the
last thing we're gonna talk about cost
this is a pilot that's coming up soon in
a few markets so you should hear more
about it which is a pilot in partnership
with local carriers or local mobile
operators how it works
is a carrier can offer mobile data at no
cost for downloads installs brands in
the stores
clicking screenshots and all these
things so if the user is one of these
users that actually is really worried
about data this no longer needs to be
part of the equation they can just be
rest assured that they can download this
app and enjoy something that they didn't
before and have fun with your app and
games thank you very much and now we'll
pass the word to Pierre who will talk
about things that you as a developer can
make to make your app smaller and more
efficient and it and reach more users
thank you thank you Vitor so we've seen
the importance of reducing the size of
your app since it directly correlates
with the number of users that will
install your app also the bigger your
app is the more likely it is to be
uninstalled now that we've seen what
Google helped how Google helps serving
small apps let's see what you can do on
your site to also optimize the size so
we'll do this in three steps first we
need to agree on the metrics you should
measure you should use to measure the
size of your app secondly once you know
what to measure you need to know how
to measure it and we've got some new
reporting in the play console to help
you with that today and thirdly with
tracking in place we're ready to take
actions and start optimizing the size of
your app and we've have also some new
tools and best practices to share with
you today which will help you do just
that okay so before we see how to
optimize your app let's talk about what
you should measure so you're hopefully
convinced by now that the size of your
app matters but what apps are we talking
about it's important to note that there
are different types of sizes you can
measure for your app and not all have
the same importance the line practiced
three ways to measure the size of your
app we have the app upload size the app
download size and the app size on device
and I'm going to explain each little bit
more details but I want to start with a
bit of a show of hands raise your hand
in the audience if you measure the size
of your app by looking at the file size
of the apk you upload to the Play
console alright almost everyone yeah
that's indeed quite a common practice
because it's easy to do that's what we
call the app upload size because that's
the size of the on disk of the file that
you upload to the play console it turns
out it's it isn't such an important
metric because not what your users will
see it's neither the size of what they
download and it's neither this nor the
this what they see when they look at the
device on the device that the disk usage
of your app what you should measure
instead is the app download size this is
the optimized size of the apk that the
users download to their devices over the
wire the optimization is performed by
Google Play and the final size is
determined by multiple factors including
the type of compression Weibull to
perform or the patching Weibull to do
from one version to another this is the
size that users see in the Play Store as
well and you can now also see it in the
Play console as done well see you later
download size is a really important size
metric to track because it's directly
correlated to your install success rate
so how can you cover can you measure it
so some of you may already be familiar
with the apk analyzer in Android studio
which already gives you the possibility
to monitor the estimated down the size
of your app it also shows you the
download size broken down by file so you
can see which where the biggest files
come from for developers publishing app
bundles the download size will vary per
device configuration because it's User
is getting a tailored version of the app
that depends on their device
configuration based on that device and
language if you've published an app
bundle before you may already be
familiar with bundle tool which is the
tool generating the apk is from the app
bundle we added a comment in bundle tool
to help you estimate the download size
of your app for the various device
configurations let's take a look at how
to use it so the comment is called get
size any outputs in a CSV format the
minimum and the maximum download size of
your app across the range of devices
your app supports in this example you
can see that my app my apps download
size ranges from 79 megabytes to 22.6
megabytes
depending on the device configuration
well you can I say it's still quite a
big range so how can we know in more
details where this which devices gets
what size so we can break down the
result by various device dimensions and
this is done through the dimensions flag
so here we asked to break down the
results by SDK version and we get a bit
more details we get a breakdown by SDK
version we see in this example that the
download size of my app is bigger on
older versions of android JMK and
smaller on l and above that's because
pre L Google Play doesn't generate
language splits so all languages are
included in the apk served to the user
now we can get into even more details we
can break down on more dimensions such
as a br
screen density and even language if you
do that then I will output a lot of rows
but you will get to see the download
sizes for each full device configuration
with this comment you can track the
download size of your app for every
build of your bundle for all your users
at the granularity you want alright so
that was download size today we're
introducing a second important app size
metric the app size on device the app
size on device is the approximate size
of your app on a user's device and as
you'll see it can be much more than just
the size of your apk after an app is
opened the app size and device can vary
quite a lot depending on how it's used
for so for the purpose of measuring the
data we will focus on the size at
installation time before the app is
opened size on device is important to
track because it's a major factor in and
installs note that it doesn't include
the cache or the user data it's just the
application size to try and understand
better why the size and device differs
from your apk size here's a simplified
diagram of what happens when an apk is
installed on a device first let's look
at the Dex files Dex files get optimized
by the platform during the installation
by a tool called Dex - oats this
optimisation will make your app run
faster but usually at the cost of a
big-sized the size of the optimized Dex
can vary quite a lot by device and by
SDK version and as I mentioned before
before it will also vary during the life
of your app depending how the app is
used second the native libraries when
you compress the native libraries in
your apk the Android platform needs to
uncompress them which takes additional
space on your users devices fortunately
you can avoid this by leaving native
libraries and compressing your apk which
allows the Android platform to read them
directly from it without having to
extract them and that's available since
SDK 22 and you get this for free with
the Android app bundle so all of this
makes for the
total size on device of your app okay so
now we have seen the two app size
metrics you should focus on don't will
now show you how you can now track these
in the play console
thanks Pierre Pierre talks about the
size metrics you should be tracking
download size which is what's delivered
over-the-air to users and size on device
which is the device storage needed for
your app now I'm going to talk about how
you can track and analyze the size data
for your apps in the Play console and
then we'll move on to how you can
actually work to reduce the size of your
app you can now track both of these size
metrics on the statistics page in the
Play console statistics reports are
highly customizable you can do things
like compare both sides metrics to each
other you can see the sizes for
different device configurations and you
can compare the size metrics to your
other app metrics such as installs and
uninstalls so for example you could
pinpoint the impact of a sudden increase
in your app size and how it's impacting
something like installs in a country
like India which is particularly
impacted by changes in size that's not
all we're going a lot further than the
statistics page today we're launching a
brand new report for app size in the
Play console you'll find it under
Android vitals which is where you can
find all of the data to do with your
apps health and performance there's lots
of new data in the app size report for
you and your team so let's take a look
in more detail you'll see two tabs for
both of the important metrics download
size and size on device at the top of
the tab will show you the size for your
latest production release compared to a
reference device and if you're using
multi apk or the Android app bundle will
show a range of sizes for different
device configurations you can also see
how you're doing compared to peers
you can actually go in and change the
peers to be more appropriate apps to
compare your size to this gives you a
target to work towards because size is
important to users and it impacts your
downstream metrics you're going to want
to make sure you're doing is better than
your peers as far as you can being able
to compare yourself to peers is a brand
new functionality we're adding to the
play console this year you can see
another example here for your apps
rating it's very powerful
you can select 8 to 12 peers to compare
yourself to and you'll see the median
value of the peer set and the difference
between your app and your peers so back
to app size the next section of the
report shows you two new metrics
relating to your users these metrics use
anonymize user data from devices opted
in to sharing their data first you'll
see the proportion of active devices
which have your app installed but have
low free device storage you can think of
these devices as having a higher
uninstall risk than devices which have
plenty of device storage secondly you'll
see uninstalls which are happening on
devices with low free device storage app
size may have been a deciding factor in
driving these on installs this is the
first time we're giving you additional
insights into what might be impacting
your uninstalls in the Play console
keeping your app size optimized and
obviously as useful as possible can help
to reduce these uninstalls we'll start
populating both of these metrics in the
coming months now we also show you a
view of your app size and how it's
changing over time being thoughtful in
how these changes happen is important
because it can impact your own installs
an honest or honest Orr's in this
example you can see when the app first
switch to the Android app bundle and the
size savings that resulted if you're
publishing with an Android app bundle or
multi apk you can also
the full range of device configurations
here the next section of the report is
data you'll only see if you're
publishing with an Android app bundle
we're able to perform a more thorough
analysis so we can actually show you a
breakdown of all the components that
make up your app size you can see how
much of your app is made up of code
native libraries resources assets and so
on the point of this chart is to help
you prioritize what to focus on you can
get a very clear understanding of the
main contributors to your apps size and
you can see how they change from release
to release we've been testing the new
report with developers and they tell us
they're really excited to get access to
this new data they look forward to being
able to sharing it with stakeholders and
the team so that they can actually
prioritize reducing app size on their
roadmaps so we've covered the size
metrics and the new reporting which
helps you track your progress the next
thing you need to do is actually work to
reduce your app size so I'm going to
pause and ask a quick question around
the room raise your hand if you're
already publishing with the Android app
bundle ok quite a lot of you is pretty
good so that's great
you for those of you not familiar with
it I'll just give you a quick intro to
the features and then I'll tell you
about the new things that we've added so
the Android app bundle is Andrews
official publishing format we introduced
last year it's open source supported in
Android studio and Gradle in buck and
for games it's already supported in
unity and Coco's creator apps which
thing have seen an average reduction in
download size of 20 percent compared to
a universal apk and partners are seeing
up to 11 percent increase in installs
from these size savings that's a huge
impact from a relatively simple switch
over 80,000 apps are using app bundles
in production late last year we shared
that apps such as Airbnb and Twitter are
you
in the app bundle many new apps have
started using it in production and are
seeing these size savings from Flipkart
and Netflix to Shazam and games like
clash of clans and minions rush google
apps are switching to this year chrome
duo Google Photos and others have all
switched and are seeing size savings the
number one feature request we've had
from many of you and some of you may be
eagerly awaiting is better testing tools
for the Android app bundle so you can
already publish that bundles to the
testing tracks and test them as normal
but this takes time and the app has to
be signed with your production key today
we're introducing a new feature called
internal app sharing it's different to
testing tracks it allows you to drag an
app bundle sign with a debug key onto a
web page to generate a URL you simply
tap that URL on any device and it will
you'll instantly install the appropriate
splits for that device it's very very
quick and very very useful and that's
not all there is to the Android app
bundle it sets you up for the future as
well
once you've switched you're able to take
advantage of modular app development
this is great for engineering velocity
and build times and it also lets you how
it also lets you customize how you
deliver features to your users so
dynamic features are coming out of beta
today with some new delivery options you
can deliver features on demand or you
can deliver features based on conditions
like device features or countries or SDK
version all developers can now publish
dynamic features to production tracks
and join apps like Chrome Facebook and
Netflix which have dynamic features in
production today with the Android app
bundle we're moving away from the idea
of a monolithic app where everything
gets sent to all of your users at
install time instead you can deliver a
lean efficient app upfront and you can
customize the experience for different
types of users there's a whole I o
session later today just on this topic
you can watch what's new with that
bundles in the amphitheater at 1:30 p.m.
or watch it on YouTube later too
ok let's get back to optimizing exercise
so on the same app size report that I've
been talking about the final section is
a list of recommended size optimizations
for your app bundle when you use the app
bundle we do a thorough analysis and we
generate tailored optimizations which
are appropriate from your app we also
order them by the expected size savings
this will help you prioritize exactly
what to work on next I'm going to invite
Pierre back on stage so he can talk
about some of the optimizations that we
are going to start suggesting thank you
so one well-known optimization that
usually provides significant size
savings you should be all familiar with
is code minification through our aid or
ProGuard for example if we detect you're
not using it it will prompt you for this
recommendation another thing we do is
scan your image assets and tell you how
much size you could save if you
converted them to web P web B is an
image format Google developed a few
years ago it has both lossless and lossy
compression and on average web P images
are typically 25 to 34 percent smaller
than comparable JPEGs and rich studio
already has a tool which allows you to
convert images to WebP II in batch or
one by one and you can then preview the
image conversion results and tune the
quality level when choosing lossy
compression alright so the next
optimization is extracting rarely-used
libraries sometimes your app makes use
of a library which is takes quite
significant space in your app but is
used only rarely by your users by
extracting this library in an on-demand
dynamic feature in the
bundle and download it only when the
user needs it you can often reduce the
size of the initial download by a few
megabytes an example of such library is
card i/o which is a library used to scan
credit cards here you can see an app
where we've extracted the credit card
scanning flow in a separate dynamic
feature in the app bundle we downloaded
when the user needs to register the card
and then we perform the scanning then we
don't forget to uninstall the dynamic
feature once it's used and no longer
necessary to free up space on the user's
device similar to large libraries you
can do the same thing with large
resources and assets to will help you
identify the large resources and assets
in your app by displaying in the list of
optimizations the biggest ones and that
download size when you expand the
optimization tip one approach could be
to extract a large file into a dynamic
feature and deliver it on demand or
uninstall it when it's been used but
also depending on the size of the file
type there are other approaches you can
take to for example for media files you
could consider streaming them instead so
all these optimization tips will be
available on this app size page and we
are actively working on adding more so
check back regularly
all of this is available today go to the
Google Play console and you can start
seeing optimizations for your latest
release in the new near future we're
going to launch a size optimization
plugin for Android studio as well you'll
be able to see optimization suggestions
directly in your IDE and what's really
cool about this is you can apply some of
the optimizations in just a few clicks
delivering billions of installs every
month there's a huge responsibility and
something at play that we keep on
working on to improve we work behind the
scenes to optimize every step of
discovery and distribution we're
continuing to build tools to help you
publish more efficient apps which can
take advantage of next generation
delivery options these are your
takeaways for today number one start
publishing with the Android app bundle
number two visit the new app size report
to get to track your data and get new
optimizations and number three you can
start thinking about taking advantage of
modular app development the final thing
we're going to leave you with is a video
really is a developer of many popular
apps in India and they've shared their
story with us how they switch to the
Android app bundle so thanks very much
everyone and have a great bio
[Music]